with us again
is andrew yang the uh can i call you a
futurist
do we accept this title you know i used
to joke ethan that
people call me a futurist but i'm
actually a presentist it's all going on
right now that's and and i was
contrasting myself with other political
figures who seemed stuck in the past
it's like everyone's
arguing for some version of the past
so so i you know but if people call me a
futurist i mean it sounds cool it makes
me sound with it and forward thinking so
i mean i'll i'll take it that is a good
point though i mean
the ideas that that you were speaking
about only
you know a year or two ago before kovid
is already here now ubi was your
was your kind of main main uh
platform and once kovit hit
this whole ubi discussion came for front
like all of a sudden this isn't such a
bad idea
yeah majority of americans now support
universal basic income that just came
out this week
and something like 76
of americans favor cash relief during
the pandemic which is
as you can tell a very close cousin to
universal basic income and we're getting
a ton of economic data right now
that's showing that the money we're
putting into people's hands has been
enormously positive
for the economy for those individuals
and families
uh for people's ability to continue to
spend money uh in their local
communities
so it's been like a large-scale
kind of involuntary ubi trial uh but i'm
happy to say that
it seems like now it's mainstream wisdom
and the majority of the american people
support it i just wish it didn't have to
be under these circumstances but thank
you all because you were ahead of the
curve pre-pandemic you were like hey
that's actually a good idea
and then now we all look like geniuses
because everyone's like we should
totally freaking do this
no the timing was crazy because once
like
once a pandemic hit and everyone started
talking about cash relief like your name
started trending on twitter because
everyone was like dude andrew
has been talking about this right before
it happened the timing was unbelievable
but what the government has done like
you said is cash relief it's not really
ubi
whereas a lot of other countries have
gone beyond
and just said you know during
during this crisis we're going to give
you cash every month
our government has stopped short of that
they're they gave one time twelve
hundred dollars
is that enough in your opinion to to
really
help people get by well it's better than
nothing but it should have been
recurring they should have
done that sort of thing every month for
virtually everybody i just want to
say uh how happy i was to see
you and gila with your help economic
relief where you're just giving folks
500
which is an enormous difference maker i
know because we know we've been doing
something similar
but our government should have been
doing that kind of thing from day one
for virtually all of us and the thing
that made me
there's a lot of things that made me
very angry about our approach uh
but we we're using the irs as a tool to
get people these checks
and that was the right move under the
circumstances but it still misses a ton
of people
there are a lot of people that are not
filing tax returns that don't make
enough money
in many cases and when we were trying to
get money to people we were just doing
what
ordinarily people would do which was
like ben mowing or
cash app or paypal i mean that's how you
and i send money to each other
when we send each other money every
night which you know
that's not what i mean but like if
individuals are trying to send money to
each other
you know like you you can just do it um
so that's what my org has been doing our
government
how can our government not use an app
that like millions of us use
like if they wanted to get money to us
like they could get money i wonder
do they it almost seems like
too unofficial the government sending
money to people through like venmo or
something
do they make their own proprietary thing
like how do they do that really
within it just seems odd for the
government to send
a trillion dollars over venmo it would
have been awesome though i mean it would
have been awesome i agree
is that is that a feasible here is that
a reality
dot gov actually i should say cash
app.gov because i'm
better friends with jack
app.gov yeah so
uh it's i mean it's fun
that joke about how unofficial it seems
um but that is the kind of move that i
wish we'd made
and at this point the vast majority of
americans know we need to do a lot more
for people
i'm friends with a guy who has
essentially a dashboard to
the financial pictures of
over two million american uh temp gig
and contract workers and so he's seeing
their financial fortunes rise and fall
in real time
and he said that like their jobs started
to evaporate
in march but a lot of them kept getting
money from the
unemployment benefits and that was like
the big lifeline for a lot of these
folks
and then he saw those benefits end in
july and then all of a sudden
stuff just starts heading down he also
said that the temp and gig
opportunities have gone down by 60
percent
writ large so a lot of these people
don't have jobs to seek out
and they had money and now they're not
having money and so he's seeing it all
uh evaporate in august so
we should be doing more of what we did
in april or we just sent people money we
should be doing
it to virtually everyone every month to
your point too ethan because they're
doing a lot of
those sorts of things in other parts of
the world right
yeah i mean we're in this situation i
don't know how people are going to
continue to get by
because like you said the the benefits
basically just stopped right where
if you're unemployed people are getting
extra 600 on top of their unemployment
and i know for a lot of people they said
this is huge
uh this is helping me a lot that's
that's ran out now right and so
i i genuinely am supe and then at the
same time you have
a in a lot of places the
the eviction moratorium uh expiring
and i feel like we're kind of on the
verge of
of a cliff that we're about to fall off
of i mean and and
and in the meantime the congress isn't
isn't pushing any new relief bills or
they're
incapable of coming to some kind of
compromise i mean
it just seems like we're right on the
blade's edge right now now
the fact that my friend with this
company and he has his real-time
dashboard yeah like you can see
people's way of life deteriorating and
disintegrating in front of you
uh something like 30 of americans had
trouble meeting housing payments
last month and so if you have an
eviction moratorium and
uh and people's unemployment benefits
start to dry up um you're going to see
mass evictions and
uh folks know
are going to be in unthinkable
situations pretty quickly it really does
make me very angry
uh that our congress has been doing the
obvious it's just showing how
dysfunctional
the government is at this point i mean
uh it's
why i ran for president and you know now
i'm shifting gears because
you know you have to do whatever you can
to solve the problem so now i shifted
gears to giving money to
folks like uh like you've been doing
thank you to everyone who donated yeah
um uh and pushing for other solutions
uh you know i'm trying to get trump out
because i think that
that none of these problems are going to
get addressed meaningfully
um unless we have a different
set of leaders uh but that nothing
i just said should stop members of
congress right now from doing what the
vast majority of americans
want to see in the form of cash relief
again you know it's like if 76
of americans are for something why is it
so hard for
our members of congress just to come
together and say oh let's just do what
everyone right
wants and it's obvious and economists
say it's the the right thing to do
well you know it it was just baffling
that like
they just they went on vacation congress
just bounced they went on vacation
without a deal
and i mean it's like just losing faith
in
and the entire system of our of our
government
i i was shocked that they just like
i find it so ironic that they're sitting
on a cushy salary
they've got health insurance they've got
pension they've got all these things
that
that normal americans would like to see
from their jobs
and for them it's so easy to just walk
away and take a vacation while
the rest well the country is burning i
mean it's it's crazy that that's even
that they can even do that well they're
in their districts right now and
hopefully they're hearing the same thing
they're hearing everyone say yo
get back there and [ __ ] pass uh
this bill or recovery bill connection i
bet they're hearing that every day all
the time i hope they are certainly
like i've been pushing in any way i can
uh and hopefully reason it'll be mail i
just hope it doesn't require something
uh disastrous for reason to prevail over
there
well they say about americans i think
churchill said this you can count on
america to always do the right thing
once they've exhausted every other
option
yes so right now they're going to
exhaust the people somehow survive on
nothing option and yeah
that doesn't work you know that the
tough part is
so let's say that i was a an awesome
uh spirited person and i ran for
congress and then i won and then i show
up it's like you show up and there's
like all this entire
giant hierarchy that's been built up and
then there are like a couple of deal
makers in your party
and you're like hey i would like to make
a deal but i don't have control over
my caucus and then we have a few lead
negotiators the other party has lead
negotiators
in this in this case it was you know
mitch mcconnell trying to rally the
republican senators and
see if they can reconcile it with nancy
pelosi's
uh uh house bill that was passed by the
democrats you go back to your district
and everyone's yelling at you and you're
like man i like i can't get this
thing done i mean part of the problem is
that you have these two sides
in congress that uh
they can go home without a deal
uh and then blame the other side and say
well they didn't yeah
um there's been a lot of talk i've seen
of a four-day work week that seems to be
something that that
you've been focusing a lot on lately
i'll tell you from my experience when i
was working a desk job in israel i
worked
a normal office job five days a week the
whole nine to five
nine to six and i was that whole time i
was like dude i could
i could do this in four days easily i
mean when you're sitting at a desk
you waste so much time and i always
thought that that idea was brilliant
because
it's got to do a wonders for morale
right i mean
have you been reading studies in
literature about that
yeah the data is tremendous around a
four-day work
week and it's also common sense because
work kind of expands to fit into
whatever time you have
you know what i mean like if i give you
a bunch of stuff to do with being like
you've got five days
it's gonna take you five days right if i
say you've got this much to do with your
four days it's definitely gonna take you
four days well especially with the
promise of an extra
you know week it's motivating yeah you
know in
israel we only have one day weekend
so you know what's funny when i moved
here
i was like this is like a dream i love
the long weekend but um i started to
feel like
god i wish i had one more day and i
started to feel guilty about that and
like
i really can't get enough can i like
wait wait tell me more
so israel like uh just as a foreigner
which i'm guessing is saturday yeah so
um
sunday is the first day of the week it's
not monday
so that is wild how about like i
consider myself a fairly
worldly cosmopolitan person and i did
not know that
yeah um school is sunday through friday
and you only have saturday off they go
to school six days a week can you
imagine that hell yeah
all right i'm gonna say something please
don't judge me um yeah i went to a prep
school that had classes on saturdays so
i actually had oh my god you can imagine
that
so weak and so i can't imagine it and it
was not
pretty horrible
yeah so i i just read about it only
recently because you've been talking
about it and i
find the whole idea so interesting and i
think
i want to read more about it and learn
what it really means because we actually
have
a business and we have maybe 20
employees so
we could decide to go that route for
everyone
but i would have to know like what
exactly it would mean
yeah you should look into it for sure
and then
maybe even run like a trial in your case
you'd run a trial but the data is very
positive where it says that
productivity uh either stays the same or
goes up
in the sense like you get the same
amount of work done uh
and then there are reduced stress levels
increased morale like the people use
that extra day off
in a way that they find restorative and
uh productive in like a you know
personal way
and so it's me it's like upside on the
personal side
and the on the business side of the
productivity side
uh there's really no loss and in some
cases there
there are positives right so uh and
to me society-wide too america in
particular and you guys have like a very
distinct
uh job if i do say so but
you know but like america generally has
this uh
this workaholism problem or
some one person called it workism which
is probably
like maybe a better name um where
keynes projected decades ago said we'll
be down to a 15-hour workweek because
we'll be so rich
and it turns out his estimates of the
top line were right like we are as rich
as he said we were going to be
but our work we are actually migrating
longer not shorter
because of the nature of corporate
culture and the economy where it's like
you have to be always on
and um available and the work kind of
creeps
and that is what's happening right now
and it's driving health problems stress
problems
relationship problems you know like that
there are uh a lot of signs already that
the american work culture is kind of
morphed into something
uh not terribly healthy and so i think a
four day work week would be a massive
improvement
for many many corporate cultures and i
gotta say like a lot of the times you're
you're
there like you're not doing [ __ ] no like
you know probably like one day a week
you're just like i didn't
do [ __ ] today
i mean i was i probably was spending 30
hours a week on reddit
i've i've gone to pages of reddit that
men
have never even known i've been to
thousands of pages back
unknown pages have read it
that was my job guys when you're at
israel you're like someday i'm going to
be a massive
internet creator and i'm going to spend
my time mining like the deepest depths
of the internet in preparation
yeah exactly you know in finland
in finland the prime minister had called
for employers
to allow employees to work not only four
days but
six hours a day so they are taking it to
the next
level that's some next level stuff
i might i might not go to that that
extreme but but i like where their heads
are at
right now does not work yeah in finland
they're saying
no work but you know uh i'll tell you
what because
as business owners we're always thinking
about like morale
and you want to retain the good and the
you want to retain the talent and make
sure that they're happy and satisfied
working there so
i'll tell you what on a four-day work
week i don't think anyone's going to
leave your
company yeah i mean
it sounds like your morale and retention
would be very very high i'm sure
your staff that are listening to this
are like suddenly nodding being like yes
yeah i don't i don't know if i can do
that for you dan and ian
because we have a production schedule
what can i do i can't give you the
you know what i'm saying i mean i'm
sorry i used to work in movies
this is this is easy by comparison there
you go so you don't work this like uh
14 hours days regularly well and this is
uh someone because i've also
run startups and most of the startups i
ran
uh we worked our asses off you know what
i mean so like it so there isn't like
uh there isn't
some something against hard work i mean
i i love working hard
you know that was one of the funny
things about running for president on
universal basic income where people like
what about work and then like depending
upon my mood i would have responded
different ways but sometimes i'd be glib
and be like i'm asian i love work
people but then you know
back off a little bit but but that that
is one of the fallacies right about the
ubi people say
oh you're just not going to work but i
feel like that's such a misunderstanding
of the human condition i mean
nobody just wants to have no purpose in
life i mean that's that's outrageous
well this is the thing that that like
you know like makes makes you
laugh is like they'll say two things
simultaneously
one work is the most important element
of human life
and without it we are lost and two
no one will want to do it if you give
them a little bit of money right
yeah that's great those two things
don't really come together it's like if
it's so crucial then wouldn't we do
it anyway maybe i think it's slightly
better
that's a great point i feel like also
the beautiful thing about ubi is that it
goes to everyone
at any different position that they are
in life
so you could be having a crisis you
could be having a meltdown
mental thing that doesn't allow you to
work right now you know you could be
having a physical injury that you can't
work right now even if you want to so
it reaches everyone at different
places in their life you know of course
yeah like it's
it's funny that you're just thinking
about this one situation where you're
healthy and you do want to work but like
you're not going to work because you
have money because you're getting it
yeah what if you have an ailing loved
one what if you have a
young child or something or mental
illness or
no yeah like right now we have this
incredible the dynamic
well we have a yeah or you're in a
pandemic we have this homeless problem
homelessness problem that's just kind of
crushing
l.a right now and if you gave each
homeless person
uh if there was that bottoms you know
social safety net i think you would see
a lot
a lot less almost probably to zero in
terms of homelessness
you know now if you had that level of
resources you could reduce homelessness
very very
dramatically the issue it would be the
transition because some of the people
that are homeless
right now are have mental health
problems or drug addiction problems and
then
and and don't may not even have a bank
account where instead of trying to send
you the money like what
what's going on but over time if you
knew that everyone had this
money that they were entitled to then
you would reduce homelessness pretty
quickly because then it would just look
around and be like wait a minute
like what's going on this person has got
like thousands of dollars of
a year in value like you know i just
need to freaking
um make sure that it's actually uh
working for them
in a way and and to the extent that
people aren't in a position where
it would work for them because of their
own volition like it'd actually be
pretty straightforward to like help it
work for them where you'd have
like an organization being like every
homeless person i like bringing to the
shelter like we're gonna get thousands
of dollars
so like let's go get that done i mean
it it's it is funny how uh market-driven
everything is in the u.s but if you give
everyone intrinsic value then all of a
sudden like
the market value starts kicking in for
people
you know the other the other kind of
nice thing i like about the four day
week is
something i i always thought about when
i was working in my
my desk job it's like
you pointed out this kind of uh
workaholic knit i think it's kind of in
israel it's the same you know in a lot
of
developed countries or around the world
i think people just
have this um overwhelming uh
pressure social pressure to show how
much they care about their
job by working unreasonable hours
you know it's like in in europe i was
always
blown away by the fact that people get
like an entire month off you know and
they're august
freaking everyone disappears i mean that
that to me is
is unfathomable that uh and then the
thing that that blew my mind is when you
learned that
like chinese new year even in china
these people people are getting a month
off
you don't see that are two months off
even in
no month off in america we don't have
that
a little less than a month we don't have
that
they travel back their hometowns in many
cases i think it's less than a month but
it's significant
um though their work week i think is
like the israeli model of six days
oh really well so they work hard but the
thing is in israel too you don't have
that
well you get holidays but not like a
designated time off
and so to me it's like we we as human
beings
need to be defined by more than just our
jobs
now i think a four-day work week would
be a massive value out of the united
states but
i think that you know you wouldn't make
it uh one size fits all for every
organization because i've been parts of
some organizations where
you probably want to have you know like
a
longer work schedule and there are
certain types of
roles and um where it makes sense but i
think as a default setting where
like the expectation is of a four-day
work week i think would be
an incredible improvement in large part
because what you just said ethan which
is like what is the purpose of life
yeah um is it our job or is it something
bigger that integrates a job includes a
job but it's not like exclusively
a job so uh
the four day work week is something that
to me would actually make work like an
appropriate
part of our lives right um you know uh
in a way that right now we have to be
honest that it's just creeping upwards
like it's it's going like from five
plus into like that zone uh
and i'm a data guy and there are very
very clear signs that
right now it's having a damaging effect
on our health mental health stress
levels relationships family formation
um and all of that stuff was
pre-pandemic
um the the post in the pandemic
uh we just have to do anything we can to
give people like a real sense of
well-being and even folks who
are doing well quote-unquote like
relatively speaking during this time are
not exactly
like necessarily mentally
doing well you know there's just a lot
of
there's a lot of stress right now that i
think
if you had a couple of days a week or
three days a week where you were
genuinely
disengaged from work it would be like
enormously helpful for so many of us
do you see yourself doing that
you know it's funny it's like it
certainly sounded like i was talking
about myself just then
um i mean for for me i'm in a similar
boat to you i think where
you know we're in a situation where
we're just trying to do positive things
and help people
like i'm very busy right now uh you know
i just spoke at the
dnc last night and then i went and
talked about my speaking at the dnc late
later in the night
so you know we're
distributing economic relief like you
we're working on this data project where
we're trying to get people paid for
their data
i'm helping these down and ballot
candidates who are running on universal
basic income because we got to try and
make it
happen for folks so i'm campaigning for
them all the time
uh i'm campaigning for joe and come on
against trump so i'm
busier than ever and it's cool in the
sense that
like the world is on fire and i i feel
like
um thanks to you and thanks to you some
other folks who believed in
in me like i feel like i've got
something of a fire extinguisher yeah
and i got a fire extinguisher
um so like i better [ __ ]
try and put the fire out because you
know it's like not everyone has a fire
extinguisher
um it's just like you guys where you
looked up too you were like wow there's
a lot of freaking
need and suffering right now and like i
can help so you tried to help like i'm
in the same boat you are where
this is a time for me to like not worry
too much about
you know like you know my own uh like
balance
[Laughter]
i mean right it's i think it's different
for entrepreneurs or
people who manage i mean obviously
it's it's important but for people who
don't have much of a choice in the
matter you know who are expected to do
things
you know when you were you were running
for president
you made it super far what were you like
the fifth candidate
around there you know something like
that you don't remember the exact number
well there were different kinds of we
could go no
yeah they're different level but i mean
i'm thinking about the people
that were yeah i might have been sixth
i like five let's say five top five
let's do it why not
but i mean i was yanking all the way i
still am
when you left the when you dropped out
of the presidential race
you endorsed uh joe biden
and you got a lot of [ __ ] for that and i
was fascinated by
the rest you remember that i was
fascinated by the response of how people
felt betrayed by the fact that you had
endorsed joe biden what i mean
what was that experience like for you to
get to have some of your uh supporters
turn on you
you know i spent a full day or so just
responding to people being like hey i
understand why you're angry
like uh because i appreciate everyone
who supported me a great great deal
uh and you know if they disagreed with
my
uh my opinion or judgment or decision at
that time i just wanted to try and
uh explain um and in my case too
joe called me and asked me for my
endorsement and i
essentially like i was like look i kind
of want to let this process play out
uh and then i endorsed him when um
to me he was going to be the nominee and
i was like all right like i should do
what i can to unify
the party right um and and bring us
together
um so i understood i understood where
people were coming from
uh and i tried to address it and
hopefully over the past number of days
and weeks like you know more people have
um come to understand
like the situation we're in and you know
like hopefully they're going to support
joe because to me it's joe or trump and
um but i get it because i i was the
burner i like
bernie a lot and bernie was right about
so much and so
if someone was like [ __ ] you yang like
you know like you you
like uh endorsed the wrong guy i'd be
like i totally get it because
like i love bernie too and like you know
at that point he had pretty much
had no chance of of winning it was yeah
i i
i am the math guy i saw the math and i
was like this is not
this is not gonna happen because like
you know like like i'll put it in
you know actual terms he needed to win
michigan um
in a significant way to have a chance
and and he did not and then i was like
this shit's over
like uh you know like because he
he like won michigan uh last time
so like you saw you know like if he
didn't win it
this time against joe's it was like you
know there was no pass
what is it like to get a call from joe
biden asking for your endorsement
what does he say to you uh
he calls i mean he's joe so he's like
he's like hey pal like you know
like you know like uh
like how's how's the family that you
know we make small talk for a little bit
and then he's like hey could we use your
support
like like we need you uh
so and you told him let's go that's
pretty epic
i will i will say this and this is
something that
um so there are folks who are running
who are politicians
and some would take that as a pejorative
and i use it as a pejorative or like a
negative term myself sometimes like ah
politicians you know because i don't
really consider myself much of a
politician
um but there is something to be said for
folks who are
effective at reaching out and like
calling in one joe's one of those people
joe's like a bridge builder and
relationship builder um
so it you know it's and i i have to say
like when you get that phone call like
it does make you like more likely to
want to help the person
yeah you know you're like oh [ __ ] you
know because you're a human being like
the human being calls you and is like
hey you want to help but be like
you know you feel like a bit of an
[ __ ] being like i mean no sorry i
can't do it
it's kind of amazing from what like what
one or two years ago
from where you were to getting a call
from the vice president
asking for your support i and i'll say
like you know joe called me more than
once too
you know so it's not even like this like
you have his number you have a cell
number
um so joe's not really the texting type
how does it go does the call come from
like i've got joe uh
i've got uh the vice president on the
phone yeah in his case it's like i've
got the vice president i think
yeah in that sense some of the other
candidates you know we actually do text
like we've got each other's cell phone
numbers
um but but joe you know like joe he's
also cool
true trader number yeah it's like you
know like the
um but i did get it and
you're right too that that like the
ascent um
was uh you know
very dramatic and and rapid again
largely
thanks to people like you and hila who
understood
uh the problems i was trying to solve
and like the approach i was taking
and had like the vision i mean i uh
super appreciative to both of you
because you're so human and there's
something about
some of the roles that we all have where
uh and you know so you know you remember
your office job in israel and why not
and like you weren't being paid to be
like
ultra human at that time you were being
paid to like do whatever the heck
the role they needed you to do for uh x
days
and it took people like you getting
behind me to get me to a point where i
could make a positive difference
uh it's one reason i'm thrilled to be
back with you all because um
yeah well you know i mean i just love
and appreciate both of you
and feel like we're in a similar boat
where you're looking around the world
just saying like
is this really where we are and yeah
let's try and
move it move in a better direction are
we looking at a cabinet position what's
going on here
uh so that's there's absolutely nothing
has been
you know uh discussed in like a
hyper-official
level but unofficially um in the
conversations we've had people like we'd
love to have you on the team and we'll
work with you like
things like that i love it what do you
want to be what's your dream
what's your dream position there so what
i've been
saying uh to
folks is that i want to try and speed us
up on these technology issues and and
we could you know i think the three of
us could talk about this stuff for hours
but our government is just so out to
launch on technology issues
and so that could be ai
that could be the selling and reselling
of our data
that could be uh media and social media
that could be
mental health issues that are attendant
with smartphone adoption on the part of
teenage girls
they're all of these issues does that
cabinet position even exist
it does not all right and there's
there's a part
but there is an advantage there because
uh
if they created a new role for me then
it's not like they'd be blocking anyone
out because it's not like they're like
15 people being like hey i really want
to be can we create
innovation and technology can we create
a new cabinet
branch yes that is something so
yeah you can that's the short answer i
mean that that seems like a great
a great place to go and perfect yang
style cabinet of technology
secretary of technology secretary of
technology and innovation
actually the washington post just just
put that out there today they said
here's the cabinet we recommend
and they said andrew yang like a
secretary of technology innovation that
advises
all of the other uh cabinet members
that would be amazing i'm lobbying for
that from now on
can we do anything i actually think joe
would i think joe could garner a lot of
of uh support by by making that happen
do we have any input in making that
happen like can we do anything
well if if people were to if there was a
groundswell of support being like hey
joe
like if you signal to everyone that
you're going to name andrew the
secretary of technology and innovation
who would help us vote for you
um they might do it because there's no
reason not to really i mean
like again it's not like a role that
exists presently and so you know it
would make him seem forward thinking so
if enough people
and this stuff you know it's not uh that
under the radar in the sense again the
washington post just recommended it
yeah so and when i've spoken to people
that like me
they were like well this like makes me
more excited about joe if yeah
in this capacity yeah totally okay let
me move on to another controversy
cnn the ultimate betrayal
so after the uh after the
uh after you dropped out you then
you took a um position at cnn as a
how how is it called it's like a
political
commentator which by the way i love
seeing you on there i'm just kidding i'm
not i'm not criticizing you
but again that was another thing where
people like oh yang
is working at cnn he's just he it's a
total betrayal
what do you say to that what do you say
to people who say that because a lot of
people say
cc there see cnn
as uh fake news right
so yeah i know it's hard to say say cnn
so what do you say to that this is
another thing where i i kind of
sympathize in the sense that
when i was the mavericky outsider
presidential candidate
you know like a lot of the media
organizations
uh you know kind of marginalized me at
various points
and there are some people that are very
skeptical of the news media
in my case when they asked me said hey
you want to come on and talk about the
debates
it was like a short-term offer and deal
and to me it was like initially i was
like oh this can be something where i
keep my
uh i keep my voice out there
and like hopefully try and do something
positive
um particularly because the campaign
ends you know you're
like thinking okay like i'm going to
start an organization and do these
things but like it seemed like a way to
maintain that place in the public eye
and then
and initially i was like well you know
who knows how long this will
go for maybe i don't like it maybe they
don't like me um
and then they said to me very quickly
thereafter they were like hey like we
like you you know you want to make this
like a little bit
um more long-standing uh
so i would understand again skepticism
where people like hey
like you know screw the media um in my
case it's like
well i used to literally like be like
fight to try and get on these networks
and be like please please like get me on
now they paid
and then now they're like having me on
and i can hopefully
both push ideas that i think are
important but the other thing
is that like i thought it was very
helpful to
normalize me to more americans because
if you look up
we had like a donald trump in the white
house in part because he was in
everyone's living rooms for
years like you're fired and like this
apprentice nonsense and then people like
oh
he's like the boss like you know and
then sort of sort of like life imitating
reality where it's like we should make
that guy president
uh so like i started out as such the
uh outsider figure that i thought that
if i could become more familiar to more
americans
where it's like oh i trust that guy you
know he's like
for some people that are like listening
to this being like i would never trust
anyone on that but you know there are
many americans who
who would trust someone more if they
were on their tv set
consistently for a period of time i love
it whenever i see you there it brings a
smile
on my face because usually that makes me
so happy
usually it's like so depressing having
this stuff on and
i don't know it's just it feels so
repetitive and you know what they're
going to say but
you always have this freshness about you
and you just talk
simply and it makes sense and you get
good ideas so
well thank you i agree
like yeah so it's been uh it's been an
interesting experience for me because
uh like i then never really done that
kind of media pre
my presidential run um but i'm glad that
you find my presence uplifting and then
i say something reasonably
i think you make a really good point
though because it's like if you think
cnn is fake news and full of all this
crap why don't we get someone on there
who
you know can bring a dose of uh reality
and realism to it right
so maybe because they don't do they give
you notes are they like yo here's our
talking points we got to stick to this
like is there any kind of shadowy behind
the scenes [ __ ] going on
uh there has not been where i'm
concerned you know they just stick a mic
in my face and being like
andrew what did you think it just
happened and then i'd like to say
something and then
you know like no memos i've gotten zero
uh direction and zero feedback
there has never been any like hey yang
like settle that [ __ ] down or you know
like
or like you know you said tulsi gabber's
name or whatever
like there's been zero of that it's been
always like
you're clear get lost
[Laughter]
so um so so that that's also something
you know it's like it's felt positive
where
just this week at the uh dnc or whatever
i thought like aoc
had been uh miscast frankly like and
underutilized and then getting the
chance to say that on cnn i was like oh
this is great
i got really excited i could actually
point out something i think it's like a
real problem with what
um you know with the decision that was
made um
yeah so i i hopefully people
like still feel like it's me i guess
like i haven't become some definitely
i can say as a supporter i mean that
that
yeah it's it's yang on tv how's that is
that a good job they pay you all right
it's not it's not uh you know it's no
teddy fresh but
[Laughter]
uh but you know i mean they do they they
do
pay me every month how does it work do
you just
on call from a certain i've always
wondered how those jobs work because
they have shows
they have different like commentators
and then they bring in the people to do
the
the co-commentary so are you on call a
certain hours a day and then they zap
you
in how does that work yeah i never knew
how it worked either
and i'm still not sure if this is how it
works for everyone but i'll tell you how
it works for me
so so they say is they say hey um
just be available and then i'll get a
ping
from someone typically at least 24 hours
in advance
saying like this show would like to have
you on uh to talk about
something that happened uh or something
in my wheelhouse
um and then the other thing that will
happen was they'll be like hey there's
this
occasion let's call it the the
democratic national convention
where we want you on every night from
this set to this
so those like the two types of do they
um contacts they get
so do they pay you a retainer or do you
get paid more the more air time you get
i get a retainer so like it's the
expectation is just that
you know if they ask me to do something
that i'll be reasonably available
but if if i say like hey yeah that seems
like a good one i'm just not free that
day then they'll be like all right
it's like wow that's awesome
so congratulations i mean
congratulations on the job i think it's
great
i'm happy you're doing it uh usps
why do we why should we burn usps to the
ground andrew
tell me what should we do about usps do
we destroy it do we dismantle it
it's not profitable i mean that's not
really the summary ethan it's like an
american life it doesn't make money kill
it
if you don't make money you're an infant
die you know it's like what
whatever the heck is that the problem is
i mean that's pretty much where we've
gotten to in american life now where
like we're trying to try to turn
everything into an economic
instrument and if like it's not uh
profitable then
you know it should stop existing uh so
the post office
i will say i think that um the the
attack on the post office stuff like i
don't think it's going to
um impact the fundamental operations of
the post office but
it is true that we we need to uh we need
to fund the post office to a higher
degree and just accept that look
it could be that mail does not make
money
uh on a you know an in on an annual
basis
uh and there are ton there are tons of
things that we do that make
our post offices less competitive anyway
it's like expecting it to make money
and then keeping it from doing things
that could make money it's just so dumb
and i don't know israel is really smart
so you probably already do this but like
in a lot of countries
they give the post office other [ __ ] to
do you know it's like you can do like
basic banking services from the post
office like there are
things you can do here in the us it'd be
like well you can't do that because it
would compete with like the
check cashers or whatever like these
these private firms that do various like
you can do a lot of routine stuff in
post offices
around the world in the us like you know
they're real restrictions on all of that
stuff
that's true i think you can do some
stuff i can't remember right now i think
you can
cut you can convert money right stuff
like that
but i but look it's in the name it says
postal service
it's a service yeah it's it's literally
just something
that's supposed to be uh provided to us
uh and i saw something it was really
interesting where
we invested a ton in the post office
early on just to connect
communities you know like that where
literally
you had these frontier settlements right
you had to like
have some dude and a horse and like a
sack a male like getting them
their mail like there were massive
investments just to try and connect
people
and that connectivity helped lead to
trillions of dollars
in economic development over time
uh and then at some point we turned on
it we're like you got to make money like
every day
you know it's just like it's like an
investment in civilization
right and i mean if you deliver a letter
to the middle of
like uh some super
remote location in nebraska i mean
there's just there's no way that that
will ever be
profitable you know but we do it to keep
our country modern and connected it's
like you said
civilization and that post office in
nebraska is a freaking hub for that town
you know like that like they
literally go in and it's one reason why
i think having different purposes for
the post office could be so important
there's another informal gathering space
that i think could be
key in a lot of communities and that's
the town library
and it's like how the hell the town
libraries you know won't make money
it's like you go in there they're like
freaking charging your arm and a leg for
like borrowing that children's book
um but but one of the things that the
town library could do
uh is to try and replace some of the
thousand plus local newspapers that have
gone out of business in the united
states because all the
content got digitized and you can't make
money off of
uh classified ads anymore because it all
went to the
it went to craigslist and so what
happens is you get rid of the local
paper in a town which is terrible it's
bad for democracy and like how can you
vote on what's going on in your town if
literally no one's even covering
what's going on in your town it's very
important for identity to have some kind
of local publication
but in towns where the local paper uh
got eliminated what happened was the
town library often ended
up putting up like a bulletin board or
like a community board that becomes the
de facto
what is going on in my town situation so
you can imagine like a revved up
version of a town bulletin board coming
out of town libraries um
but like there are things we need to
invest in uh
in a lot of these communities that are
getting
decimated right now because they don't
make money
well that's i mean that's sad and i
think it's something we really need to
kind of change in how we view a lot of
things that
not everything's going to make money i
mean jeez how do we convince ourselves
that this was
this was the right way to evaluate
things i mean it's wild
i mean it's been a yeah it's been like a
massive
conditioning of american
what is the last 40 years what does it
say about human beings as
workers you know if
if you if you can't look at anything and
not see its value if it doesn't make
money
what does it say about human beings
well this is what i was running on
before was that i i knew that we'd been
conditioned to think that
we all needed to be economically
productive and then i said you know what
technology is going to
surpass our productivity in a lot of
these arenas
pretty quick and if we don't start
evaluating ourselves in a different way
then it's going to lead to disaster and
now we're seeing some version of it
um with the pandemic uh and so i think
universal basic income would very
quickly disentangle
uh this confusion the the the
mixing of economic value and human value
because if you all just start getting
money
for breathing for living for existing
then
you can start to feel like okay we all
have some worth that's independent of
uh how much money i'm making at any
moment in time
uh and then that alone would humanize
your perspective really quickly
do you uh are you you i know you've
already endorsed joe biden
but is there any chance we can get you
to vote for kanye 2020 vision
[Laughter]
well i'll tell you guys the story
because it's fun but like a mutual
friend actually connected me with kanye
cell
phone and so like he was just like hey i
wanted to connect you with kanye because
he wanted me to talk to kanye about his
run uh because you know i ran for
president and psychiatry was going to
tell katie what the presidential deal
was
um so then kanye called me i missed the
call like uh so i played phone tag with
kanye i got like a text
message from him and uh and then um you
know when i was like
you know like okay like if he wants to
connect it'd be all good and we have
some mutual friends
um uh i you know
obviously like the friend that put us in
touch was one and a nine others too
uh so uh you know kanye is a creative
genius and
uh like i'm definitely not gonna be
voting for her but
that's interesting you guys never
connected i would
i wish you guys connected i'd love to
hear that you know what i should do
right now is i should
[ __ ] call ya while we're out there
okay what's
[Laughter]
would you mind giving his phone number
to ian ian our
employee is a huge kanye fan
is there anything you want i don't meet
your idols you know
ian is there anything you want yang to
text kanye
well let's see if i have this [ __ ] in my
phone hang on
[Laughter]
ask him where the album is that's it
okay
it's 307 and i'm kidding
bannon just went to prison for the great
build the wall
i gotta say build the wall it's so funny
how it quickly went from
mexico will pay for the wall to
will pay for the wall too i'll just i'll
i'll
i'll just keep the money there's no wall
i'll just
pay for the wall to how about you pay
for the wall
how about you pay me the money and then
i
spend hundreds of thousands of dollars
in it i mean it's it's it's incredible
that um were you blown away by that
build the wall gofundme because when
that came out it was blowing my mind
i mean it was just it was so active i
couldn't not
i saw people saying i just donated my
entire tax refund
three thousand dollars and these are not
rich people right
i'm sure they could have really used
that money especially now and
like 25 million dollars how many how
much wall does that get you like
quarter mile you know
actually so i did this exercise when i
was trying to figure out what was going
on with like the truckers and like
how much would cost to lay a highway
across the country that would just
accommodate robot trucks i was trying to
figure out
like like if you're going to save tens
of billions of dollars a year
like would it just pay pay off just to
like make a
a highway that's like eight lines wide
that's just for robot trucks
and i did the math and it turns out yeah
you could
you it actually would pay for itself if
you just decided to [ __ ] like just
like like lay the robot super highway
just wait how much
robot trucks go back and forth um it
costs somewhere in like the
the low billions that's it you get your
money back um over time
wait when you say when you say low
billions are we talking like
like below 500 what does that mean low
billions what's what's
well so i was like one so it was
and so i you know i haven't done the
math in a while but like i was
i was trying to figure out i was like so
this the cost savings around
uh automated trucking are tens of
billions of dollars a year
and but the main impediment is our
infrastructure because like we have
you know big highway problems and you
also have this
uh political problem that if you had a
robot truck that
uh killed someone on the the highway
that people would be like oh
like you know [ __ ] the robot trucks um
so then i was like okay
like like could you make it so there was
no pedestrian traffic on this
highway um by just making a new highway
and i was like how expensive is it to
make a new highway in the united states
of america so like i found out what like
the per mile was and then i
like the thousands of miles the rest of
it
so then like you'd do a similar estimate
for the wall it was where i was going it
was like how much does it cost to make a
wall over like
like how long it's like what kind of
wall can i get for 25 million
not much of a walleye i mean i'd i'd
love to see what like
and and the the thing i mean all of its
averages because like there's certain
parts where you get a lot of wall for
that much money because like the train's
really nice and then other places you
could be like i can't build a [ __ ]
wall here
like you'd have to find like the most
upper two place in any way
um well it is fantastic i think that
they ended up just parked i mean they
didn't really pocket the money but they
like bought a boat they were they
actually well steve bannon got charged
for
um laundering money and wire fraud
so they were like were laundering the
money they were funneling it and like
the guy who set up the foundation bought
a boat it was [ __ ] awesome
like there's always a boat involved yeah
there's always a boat
that's that's that's the cardinal rule
isn't it
yeah it's like like you know i did
something
illicit if i just turn up and be like
okay you gotta come see the boat
yeah exactly it always has some name
that somehow related to some shady way i
made the money
being like steve bannon got arrested on
a boat even
oh he was on the boat when he was
arrested it wasn't
his own boat he was on it was actually a
weird twist to the story he was on some
chinese billionaires boat
and they boarded the boat and arrested
him out on the high seas it was like an
interception
what the heck that's wild
that you know that sounds like a movie
scene yeah
like chris hemsworth like comes down to
like the they should have sent chris
hemsworth to arrest him
that would have been awesome yeah i see
a true documentary coming out about this
called build the wall
or something about like the high crime
documentary
andrew if you get this cabinet position
which we're all hoping for
tell me tell me what are those first
things that you think like
you're sitting down in america you're
part of the president's cabinet
what do we need to do first what is the
most pressing things we need to address
in this country america i mean
clearly it's cash relief and universal
basic income you know it's like that's
like the simple thing
um it sounds you know that's to me the
single best thing we could do for people
so let's say
if you say something technology related
then i i you know i
i'd actually choose something related
which is what we talked about earlier
around the fact that we didn't actually
have a system set up to get people money
so we use the irs check distribution
system
um and i think it's bad for our
confidence in our government
that it sucks so bad at a lot of these
things
where like if you go to uh
your bank's website or whatever you just
expect [ __ ] to work
generally at a certain level um and then
so you'd be like well
why did the government have something so
one thing i'd love to invest in would be
essentially a citizen portal
where if there was something like we're
trying to get you money or trying to get
you information
or so the lamest version of this would
be a citizen portal where
it's essentially like here are all of
these links to other [ __ ] government
websites that you can go to like that
would be the the absolute worst version
the best version would be so
[Laughter]
you know i mean like one of those boards
where it's like here's a
freaking flurry of websites to go to
[ __ ] you but no
but like like the good version would be
like a
a slick interface where you know like
the
information from let's call it your tax
returns
uh or uh from
uh the passport office or wherever the
heck like could actually be
compiled because part of the thing that
makes me angry right now is that
like you're hearing a lot of messages
from folks all the time
associated with politics which is like
trust us trust us you gotta trust us and
it's like well
like you guys don't really deliver at
the same level as like
some of the other organizations i'm used
to interacting with
um so i would love to try and help the
government deliver at
like uh on a technical level because i
think it would be enormous for our
confidence
uh so that would be something i would
love especially if it was tied to
universal basic income because i think
that there is a relationship
where um we need to actually know who
you are
know how to get you money have to have
some kind of secure
relationship with you and interface with
you if we're going to try and
you know add value don't you think the
big
problem is that all of our elected
officials
and even you know uh joe bide i mean how
old is joe he's like 74 or something
like that i mean
um i think i think he's uh like 76 or 77
i think
um i i don't want to misspeak i should
know that he's
he's in israel yeah okay oh you're
looking it up yeah okay let's see
i mean maybe when your team can yeah
look it up uh zach
he's uh 77 years old whoa
so don't you think that's the we need
young people who understand this like a
70s i've no 77 year old people they're
not
interested in cash app do you know what
i mean
they understand checks and that's not
their fault
it's just the way it is but i think
like we have this tendency of electing
especially lately
old people to office even donald trump
is in his 70s right he's like 72 73
years old
i mean these although he's a little 74.
to be oh 74. check that one somehow he
doesn't
somehow trump i guess he's got a young
he's got a young energy yeah such an
[ __ ] he's got that [ __ ]
he energy a lot i think he does a lot
with this he does like a spray tan
and then he's used to the cameras i
think he just on camera i think he comes
off like that
obviously i never met him in person but
i have a feeling if you saw him in
person he would look that age
do you i do give him credit he's he has
a more youthful
spirit for whatever reason and he's on
twitter that's pretty
that's pretty epic but that being said i
don't think trump uses cash app either
and so what we need is peop is younger
people i really truly think we just need
younger people and that's one of the
reasons not that was one of the reasons
why i liked you right
and one of the reasons i like aoc is
that we just like aoc
does instagram live every like
super frequently to talk directly with
her uh
people yeah yeah she's she's like a
digital native
uh i think the average age of a member
of congress is 62
to your point ethan so he's not just
presidential candidates right someone
called it a gerontocracy it's like a
rule by the old
we essentially have a gerundocracy in
the united states of america
for a number of reasons uh one of the
main reasons
is that after you get into washington
you should try and stay there forever
and it's actually very hard to defeat an
incumbent so you have folks
like um nancy pelosi i believe is around
joe's age
um and she feels great but
she does but our leaders are
of another generation uh because of the
way the
structure this is the the structures are
set up
and it's one reason why i'm four term
limits um where
you should go to dc as a term of service
get something done and then get out and
it would help keep our legislators more
current and fresh and modern to your
point ethan because
if you go to dc you'll find it is not
exactly a tech friendly town uh you know
like you go i'll tell the story that was
gonna make you angry but it'll be
totally consistent with your
understanding of the world
so uh so i was on the trail and then
there was like this uh
asian kid he's like you know
mid-20s maybe um and he interned at his
congressional office
and then they asked him to like uh
do do something um uh
like answering messages or data related
like in the office
and he was smart so he set up like a
program to like
automate the process and make it so that
okay like this thing will like
happen more seamlessly and like you know
like less labor
um this will be great and then they
yelled at him for it and said like no we
didn't want you to do that
like uh like where we actually
preferred the way that like the other
person uh
could just understand and just like sit
there and like just peck at it
um all the time he was like what the
hell is going on there's like a
congressional office and so he left he
now works at facebook
he like went and worked in dc for like a
summer was like
they are freaking stuck in like the
stone age let me get the hell out of
here and then he like peaced out to
silicon valley so like that that is the
general culture in dc where you go there
and you feel like you just rewound
uh like a number of years and if you go
into some of these government agencies
it's much much worse because some of
them have been underfunded so you have
like very strange
patchwork technologies uh from past
years
uh you know like i mean i might be
exaggerating but probably not my much
like windows like 2005 or whatever like
you go in and they'll just be a
bit maybe stuff all over um in in
different
uh different government organizations so
it
that so that's that's the government we
have um and like you said before it's
like not really anyone's fault
um but we need to try and speed them up
um and if i'm in position to try and
move that
in a better direction like i would take
it and do everything i could
it sounds really we have to necessarily
yeah we have to do that
i mean i think the i think the problem
is that
the rate of technology has cert has
passed
our our people it's been going so fast
that it's past them right when joe biden
was a one
in his 40s even 50s
like 25 26 7 years ago
it was uh we were 1995.
i mean i don't even know that
smartphones were popular then i don't
think no not even close
they were not not even close right so i
mean in
in his own experience in
government the technology has ran around
them like 30 times
so yeah it's a new it's a new world they
got rid of the office of technology
assessment in 1995 the year you just
perfect
the perfect time to get rid of it yeah
that they had a
they had a department that advised
members of congress on what technology
is jews you know they should care about
and like the opinions like
why did they do that um why did they get
rid of the office of technology
assessment
uh you know like it was like to quote
unquote save money which is like the
most asinine thing in the world because
the budget of the entire thing was like
25 million it was like a [ __ ] drop in
the bucket you just had some smart
people around telling you it's like hey
so you know where the legislators get
their technology guidance from now
the technology companies and the
technology companies are like do
absolutely nothing because everything is
perfect
and then the legislators are like yeah
that sounds about right
like perfect that yeah whatever requires
the least of me
yeah so and especially if you're
donating 25 million
to my campaign that's fantastic there
was a period and it's been interesting
to see the
pendulum swing somewhat so silicon
valley could do no wrong for a long time
where dc is connected
like oh you're like the innovators
you're the
super value creators and you're rich as
[ __ ] and you donate to my campaign so
let's just like
leave you the heck alone and just sing
your praises every chance we get
uh and then that pendulum has swung
because of
uh like facebook screwing some things up
and and some other problems uh so now
everyone's starting to turn on a
turn towards them and be like wait a
minute like you know
is this really been like cool that
amazon is
you know like uh so one of the things
that i think amazon did wrong there you
know a bunch of things but like
there's diapers.com where they just
lost money on diapers for a while just
like for
diapers.com to sell to them like like
amazon did that sort of thing
just because i don't i i know about that
story correct me if i'm wrong
so they basically like diapers.com was a
popular website they're selling lots of
diapers
amazon lowered their price below that
to the point where they were losing
money just to put them out of business
and then they raise their prices back up
when they go on they're not cool
yeah i think that's so they go out of
business it was like they come to
diapers.com be like hey guys you guys
are awesome how about
takeover and then diapers.com is like no
and then amazon's like oh we'll see
about this
then they lowered prices to a point
where diverse.com was like
hemorrhaging money and then they were
like okay i guess we will sell to you
now and then amazon's like that's what i
thought and then as soon as they buy
them then the prices go back up
that's a that should be is that illegal
um
that is illegal yes uh or it's illegal
in the in the sense that it's uh
anti-competitive behavior it's against
anti-trust law
um so so that sort of thing has been
coming out now is something similar with
and this was like to me the biggest
nonsense was when uh mark zuckerberg
uh was asked like hey um the people the
founders of instagram are worried that
if they didn't sell to you that you were
going to
try and uh uh put them out of business
and now compete with them
go into destroy mode i think was though
the terminal used
this destroy mode and then mark was like
no
i never would have done that like we all
know it's like like if instagram hadn't
sold uh
to facebook you know there would have
been a freaking like instagram clone out
like that
uh and so so that this is
officially you know it violates
antitrust law to do
certain anti-competitive things uh like
that
but the the reality is like of course
that you know if you're in that
industry like you're going to do
everything you can to try and
crush anyone who could potentially end
up taking your business
i think you have to assume there's a lot
of that going on we don't know of with i
mean any company that gets to be that
big you're looking at the microsoft's
you're looking at
the amazons you're looking at the
facebooks i mean
you can't i mean correct me if i'm wrong
can you get to be
that big of a company without anti-trust
violations without somebody like
competitive behavior yeah
it would be difficult and the thing that
most people don't realize now
and this is one reason why i think
universe-based income so vital among
others
is that some of these companies have
essentially just like left
orbit in terms of business physics like
you think okay like i'm a company i need
to like you know
be ambition and treat my workers well
and like sell
sell things that are profit there are
some companies at this point just like
like i'm worth a trillion dollars i
don't even need to make money nothing
matters like
what's that you're like a cool startup
like i can buy you for 400 million
dollars and everyone's rich and i don't
even care
like they're just so unfathomably big
that like that that not like nothing
applies i think tim o'reilly called it
like super money
it's like at some point you just get
super money and then
like nothing matters and then we still
try and pretend
and what was funny is when they got
brought into congress like they pretend
too it's like oh we started in the
scrappy company they're like
they think it's like freaking at this
point they're almost like countries unto
themselves
so they're just so staggeringly
enormously
wealthy and they have now at this point
their stock market valuations are
propped up
in so many ways that they can almost
do no wrong uh and
in that environment they're just gonna
keep sucking up more and more
value like that the thing i kept saying
to folks on the trail was like look
amazon's worth a trillion bucks
paid zero in taxes soaking up 20 billion
dollars a year in commerce closing 30
percent of your stores and malls and
that was pre-crisis it's like
you know these this thing's like a black
hole so it's just gonna just
suck more and more value in and we're
not gonna see anything coming out
um and you think it's like oh it's
because they're like out competing at
some point they just left orbit
and it and that the funny thing about
amazon is like there have been periods
in its past where it didn't even make
money
but at this point you look at it and
being like there was a walmart executive
who complained
to me he said how can you compete
against a company that doesn't even need
to make money
and this was walmart which is sort of
ironic because yeah walmart obviously
like crushed every
yeah like mom and pop retailer
yeah like i joked with the walmart folks
it's like they were like the tanks
that came to american communities around
the country just like ran over every mom
and pop
and then they were like we did it we
conquered america and then amazon's like
a
[ __ ] spaceship like hovering over
them it's like
we don't need to obey the laws of
gravity anymore they're like
walmart's looking up like what do we do
and then you have our government over
here and like that they're just like
you know the government doesn't
understand what is going on and just
looking up being like
yeah like amazon's a company like any
other
that's like the it's yeah they have
their own
and i mean if you look at what's going
on with amazon like jeff bezos is so
rich
he bought the washington post with
essentially like pocket change from his
couch
like you know like the washington post
is a very very influential publication
that happens to be like the main
news source in our nation's capital like
do you think that
you know he literally and and he has
been relatively hands off like he
has he doesn't go in and be like right
about this right about that but it is
it's telling it's that like
amazon up here jeff bezos like
you know up here and then like you know
our nation's major media like news
source for our legislators was like down
here and he was like yeah
like sure he just like like took a
couple hundred million out of the couch
and just you know i mean he's worth at
this point hundreds of billions anyway
sorry no that was fascinating and i
think it under really
too it's terrifying i think that analogy
of it's like walmart
came in with the tanks and but they
weren't thinking big enough and
amazon came in with the ufo spaceship
and just zapped them
i kept thinking about the video games
you play when you're like
you keep finishing and you replay it
again with all the upgrades yeah just
way stronger every time okay yeah read
big
strong i want to wrap this story because
it's to me it was interesting so the
founder one of the founders of
diapers.com was a guy named mark lore
so then amazon crushes diapers.com
absorbs them
mark lore becomes rich but he's mad at
amazon
so he comes back for revenge years later
and starts jet.com raises
i think you raised like like 500 million
dollars a billion dollars being like we
are going to out compete
amazon and e-commerce like he's like i
have found the way
okay and so then so he got
all of these investors to pile into
jet.com
and then jet.com is like spending i do
remember jet.com
no no no
jet.com they had i think their color was
purple they had like jet and some smiley
so jet.com spends hundreds of millions
trying to fight it out with amazon
in e-commerce and then walmart buys
jet.com
as a way to try and make themselves
competitive against amazon
in e-commerce so so that's like the
how it all fit together it's like mark
laura came back for revenge
and then ended up like getting absorbed
by walmart in a
relatively futile attempt to try and
bring down the spaceship that's so
weird what ah that's so funny
i guess it never happened i mean walmart
failed to
to make it competitive it sounds like
yeah i don't think it's worked out
i mean like it's uh
had to do something hold on let's see if
jet.com is still
i mean i hope not it just literally
redirected to walmart.com
yeah uh i think they paid a billion
dollars for jet.com
like if you can look look up that were
they just thinking like look we can't
deal with another one of these
i just wanted it was literally to try
and bring on mark lore
to be like the amazon killer because if
there was like any human
that represented like the diapers guy
yeah that was like the david it was like
a lie there was this guy mark lore and
he had a
chip on his shoulder because he was like
i'm back
you destroyed my diapers.com uh
spaceship and now i'm back with like
jet.com and anyway
i i found uh that story really
interesting in large part because mark
was so compelling that he raised
hundreds of millions of dollars
uh for an e-commerce company to try and
rival
amazon i thought that was like the most
amazing act of salesmanship i had ever
heard i was like
wow this guy must like be the most
convincing dude in the world
well they all they all got they all made
money it sounds like by
by the end of it except walmart
i think that's correct yeah yeah that's
correct but i think it really underlies
this issue of how can we possibly govern
in the face of such super money
if our regulators and our elected
officials don't even
understand what they're looking at like
their understanding of what's going on
at a company like amazon is so uh
terrestrial
if we're talking if they're in outer
space these guys are
you know on the ground every week i go
on amazon now i found
i find more and more creepy stuff like
at first they just had a few like amazon
basic items
now it's like every product that you
look up they already have an amazon
brand that makes it
it's amazing i just i don't know it
creeps me out yeah it's super weird they
have they have their own brand for
literally
everything is as minute as like a pen
a lighter to as big as like uh
well any clothing thing you would look
up like shopping products
every everything they have it they're a
machine so what they do is they have
this marketplace and then they have this
giant data dashboard they figure out as
soon as like something's selling at this
turn level right they're like
they go and make it it's just they they
go and make it and so you have these
horror stories of this company being
like
you know i sold on amazon i was happy
until one day like you know the their
competitor came and i couldn't get into
the search listings and now i
am dead and like they they're this
giant uh money machine
that just comes in and like it's a
combination of like endless resources
and endless access to us and our needs
and then endless data
uh in like there's no there is no real
competition um there's something
like there's something that has changed
about capitalism
um and and the problem is that we
pretend it's still like the 70s and 80s
like that there is like a genuine market
between firms when you have these
these companies that have just reached
unprecedented
scale size resources
and it's being facilitated by this new
version of
of the markets where there are certain
companies that just everyone's going to
pile into
because they're absorbing more and more
of the economy
it's like you you look up and just you
know you ask anyone it's like
um you know like like amazon apple
facebook
uh google would be the big ones where
you just look up and being like hey
you know if you close your eyes and open
them 10 years from now like do you think
those companies will still be
um kicking ass and dominating like the
answer is yes unless
uh unless the government were to change
something for one of those companies
and you're starting to see glimmers of
that
possibility because people
are starting to recognize some of the
extremes um
i i may be part of this conversation
moving forward too
uh oh jeff bezos just found his biggest
worst enemy
he's not mark jeff you've been looking
in the wrong place
you've been looking the wrong way okay
in closing i want to ask you
one final question you have endorsed
uh joe biden tell me why do you think
joe biden will make
a better president than donald trump
joe biden would make a better president
of the donald trump on many many levels
but the things i love about joe number
one he's actually a good dude who
cares about people and like wants must
do right by people
number two is he's really not very
ideological he's more of like a
pragmatist where he's like what are we
gonna do
and as part of his pragmatism he's a
consensus seeker he tries to figure out
what the folks around him think is the
right approach and he's not going to be
someone being like no
screw you like i'm sure like the way to
go and it's not what you're saying like
he'll actually be like well if people
uh think that this is the way to go like
i'm into it
and then the third thing uh is was
something i said
um at the convention which is that joe
has this quality where anything he says
becomes the new reasonable
um like he came out with a two trillion
dollar green energy proposal
that could have been straight out of the
bernier arc like uh
playbook and if one of them had said it
people would have been like oh
like you know aggressive pie in the sky
and then joe says and everyone's like
yeah that's cool
[Laughter]
you that that that if joe gets on board
with something or
champions and then all of a sudden it
becomes the new mainstream
and so you have to ask yourself it's
like okay maybe i disagree with john
some stuff but it's like
what what's my preferred path trying to
convince joe that this is a good idea
or trying to convince donald trump that
he should you know
like adopted a complete completely
different approach to governance
uh and yeah i mean that that to me is a
no-brainer mm-hmm
andrew yang future secretary of
technology and innovation
love this potentially and if that
happened i certainly have you two
and a lot of other people to thank but
the big thing right now is just for us
to help each other try and get through
this mess
and you know stay strong and healthy
ourselves because you can't help anyone
if you can't
you know like uh help yourself but then
if you do have the capacity to help
others please do lend someone a hand
because like someone in your life needs
a hand
can we count on an interview from
washington dc
a year from now yeah i mean definitely
like if i'm the secretary
of technology innovation uh
then we'll have so much to talk about
and yeah i agree
i'll even end up being like one of these
types of being like hey send me i
ideas citizens because i am now your
and andrew if there are ufos will you
tell us
that you have access if i find out there
are ufos uh
i will tell people because we all know
they're there already okay andrew let me
ask you this
if someone's like okay andrew we're
gonna give we're gonna tell you the ufos
and the aliens and all this crazy
[ __ ] exists but you can't tell anyone
do you tell us
depends on who it is really i mean you
know if it's someone i can be like sorry
man
like i just had to tell people that
people always say that but there's no
way you would actually be able to tell
us
don't you see the problem i i do see the
problem if they bring me into the circle
of
ufo trust then it's hard to run outside
of the circle
and tell ethan and hila just before you
die
just get the truth twice yeah blink
twice on your on your deathbed
um that done deal deathbed ufo
confession yeah go
all right andrew was a it's been a
pleasure as always
i wish you lots of luck and success i'm
enjoying following everything you're
doing fantastic
and i'm along with the yang gang all the
way so
good luck thank you so much and we're
right there with you
thank you both for everything you do and
you know i i hope the little guy is
doing great
yeah he is he's doing awesome he is yeah
he is thank you and your kids too i mean
now
you're at home you're spending time with
the family that's fantastic i know it
was hard on you during the campaign
yeah you can understand why as parents
it was
the hardest thing about running um
but i'm happy to say you know yeah they
remembered who daddy was
that's good and and and now i'm under
foot all the time
when i'm not you know zooming all right
andrew take care
all right thanks guys so much you all
right talk to you soon
bye
you